as were mentioned in the keynote what is
different about Strava the Strava
experience on the watch let's Robert
trance Rob is an activity tracker at
least part of it is it's a social
network of athletes that workout and
they're able to compare their activities
to one another and so having Straubel on
your watch allows you to then record
your activity and importantly now with
the updates we have access to the
heartrate monitor which allows athletes
to train in different heart rate zones
as an example and to know when they're
in a place where they're actually
exerting themselves or not exerting
themselves there were some interesting
features in terms of being able to send
your heart rate to someone else which I
don't know maybe you would you do that
once and then never again but then how
how big a step forward is what we saw
with the watch stuff today what I think
it's very significant in the before if
you go back to when the Watchers
released all the negative reviews or raw
performance which mostly was about these
apps that ran on your phone and on the
watch and it kind of feels like the
original iPhone when they had web apps
as the sweet solution for developers it
just wasn't a great experience in actual
apps are what changed the world as they
talked about today and I think actual
apps will change the experience on the
watch sniffling by the way all four of
us are wearing wearing our Apple watches
do you feel do you guys feel like this
is something you can't live without now
that you've been wearing it for a while
or do you feel like it's a nice to have
I think it's clearly a nice-to-have as
long as it doesn't connect to the
internet what was interesting is native
apps start to kind of cut the cord to
the phone and if this were ever a
standalone device that maybe it would
get to that level Brian I think it's
it's it's definitely a device willing to
we're happy to have could I live without
it
probably but I think it's an addition I
think some parts that are great the
notifications for me make a lot of sense
that's not overwhelming but not
overwhelming and I think the changes
that made today make it actually much
more functional especially for native
apps is gonna be a big deal a lot of the
responsiveness issues I think a lot of
the things that have already popped up
this feedback will be addressed you know
obviously the availability to do native
apps will improve the experience and the
speed and the efficiency of everything
but a lot of things they're talking
about our way way way far in the future
for example using your watch as a remote
control for your house I mean how far
away is something like that well
something that involves lots of pieces
is gonna take a long time particularly
when comes the house because these are
big goods that you only buy occasionally
so I think that is the long term vision
well this is kind of my identity and I
interact with my entire environment
that's super compelling but you need to
get there first and I think what it is
now with the notifications with the
complications they talked about today I
can look down and see the sports store
which is what I'm particularly excited
about it gives it a reason to exist
until it becomes kind of that center of
your existence I think is long-term cool
Aaron what's it been like for you guys
developing for the Apple watch has been
a good experience what's been difficult
about it it's a brand new platform so
that's the most difficult thing
brand-new development environment for us
and so we have to wait for that to
mature often we're kind of in the weeds
of while it's maturing so that takes
time but I think at the end of the day
it's a new form factor it's a new model
for interacting with information and so
that's the thing that I think is
innovative here the the platform will
develop more apps will happen will
become more capable so there's a great
future for it and
now you have early days Bryan any
revisions to how big a business you
think the watch can become now that it's
been out there in the wild for several
weeks well I you know we've said this
will be the best-selling new product at
Apple in its history I've had sold
nineteen point five million in the first
twelve months we have 23 million in the
first twelve months for Apple watch and
I think again bringing these apps and
the apps is going to is what's going to
drive demand here right I mean people
look at the watch it's cool and there's
certain functions that you like like
that one thing there are very few apps
that actually work really well on the
worst one point five million apps and
developments better performance will be
huge forever watch for sure then what
else do you want to see come to the
watch well I mean I'm excited in the
long run again you have that connected
or I don't need my phone at all in the
mean time I I mean you can't overstate
the difference in performers that native
apps are gonna provide it's the same
reason we use apps on our phone not the
web just it's a way better experience
and that's gonna be the case in these
new kinds of apps